[Music]
yes I'm sinning the Ouija board cliche
and a Ouija board movie in fact I think
we G in its original Sanskrit means bull
that's done over and over again to the
point of being a dick to a movie
audience first
based on my initial research there are a
ton of way to board rules so I hope she
doesn't actually know them all there
that might be the first half of this
movie this year you can check based on
my limited googling this is less of an
actual function of the Ouija board
planchette and more of a made-up thing
for the plot mostly a mechanism for jump
scares like this one also the planchette
says copyright 2013 on the inside which
means either these are the
fastest-growing children in the world or
this is symbol the window to another
room also has a piece of plastic that
could stab you in the eye if you're not
careful you can never play alone young
Debby would be pissed at slightly older
present aw for disobeying one of the
three Ouija rules she knows also she
doesn't even do the chant or circle the
board before starting no wonder this
girl gets haunted and subsequently
killed
she doesn't even follow her own damn
rules you know you've always been like
this right like what just a total and
complete spaz spaz shaming it's
fascinating that in all the houses where
horror films occur that the lights are
on but the room still managed to be
almost completely dark why is this ghost
girl or ghost mom opening the laundry
room door in the back door she obviously
has no reason to leave the house since
her next victim is right here this girl
must be really into conservation because
despite being haunted by an evil spirit
she still manages to turn off as many
lights as possible when it comes down to
it we G is the third in the trilogy of
Hasbro films transformers Jojo
battleship oh you say that's for movies
man except mice in a bit but you see
what we're going for there surely there
were easier less decorative ways to do
this also hats off to the Christmas
lights manufacturer the carpenter that
built the banister and Debby for tying
the Christmas lights if any of them have
been even slightly less than perfect
Debbie would have fallen straight to the
floor also based on the way she fell and
subsequently hanged she clearly didn't
flop over the banister nor does it look
like she jumped off the side which would
have caused some slight swinging back
and forth it looks like her lights were
hung directly over and she dropped from
exactly that point which means the
suicide was extremely premeditated or
there is some paranormal strongman that
dropped her we're approximately 1/8 of
the way through this movie and are just
now getting to the title card but I
thought this is your big
the guy lien isn't going to go in this
camping trip with her boyfriend because
she needs to stay behind and get caught
up in all the ouija bought her
boyfriend's camping trip will probably
also end up in some sort of wrong turn
cabin in the woods Texas Chainsaw
Massacre type of scenario so she was
screwed either way over-the-top
touchy-feely friendship dad writes a
vague text message to daughter because
what could this be about and brought
flowers that be like this kind that's at
least two different kinds of flowers
maybe three also while we're here a
teenager in 2014 named Debbie no I let
them die like she did now that Lane has
ventured into Debbie's room during
Debbie's week I'm starting to think that
the script for this movie was just an
Ikea instruction manual for a horror
movie even though Debbie used all her
Christmas lights to hang herself they
remain inexplicably on her mantle and
over her windows is it possible we've
never send a movie just for being plain
awful I mean but he often send the
elements of a movie and you can sort of
tell the movie sucked because everything
sucks but we tease like a starter kit
for horror it's like if somebody remade
train pulling into a station and
expected an audience to run out of a
theater screaming like it was 1895 here
that's crazy
picked out your college they aren't even
lazily throwing in useful exposition
anymore she's drugged pictures of what
our dorms would look like so many
pictures of a small cube with two twin
beds thank you for watching the house
while we're gone why does Lane need to
watch the house while they're gone it's
winter so you shouldn't need any lawn
care and can't you tell the post office
to hold the mail and you don't have any
pets and you that's why teenage girl is
watching a video that she took on a
digital camera and not an iPhone because
Nikon apparently has a deal with all
horror films to make it seem like
teenagers still buy and use digital
cameras all lanes videos on her digital
camera are from different places and
times and don't seem to be in any
particular order so they can reveal
certain things about these relationships
between these characters the guys are
back who are the guys doesn't matter
they're back Wow nearly everybody this
girl knows is taking a trip right now
I'll text you when I get there I'm a dad
and I text even when your best friend
dies shotty pool covering wait maybe
Debbie isn't dead
she just stuck in the upside-down maybe
all the subsequent events of this movie
could be avoided if somebody would just
properly put this thing away
Lane reaches up and grabs the board
after inexplicably feeling the need to
go into Debbie's closet hey jerks gear I
didn't even hear you come on of course
not then we would have been robbed of
this cheap jump-scare designed to
distract everyone from the fact that
nothing has fucking happened
well that's interesting because during
the last conversation you had with her
before she died she said remember that
game recently where you ask questions
about the future the Ouija board yeah I
played it and you were the one the
fucking said it's called
the Ouija board never even got to say
goodbye yeah you seem real broken up
about it a few days ago I went to her
house to try to talk to her she didn't
even want me to come inside well she was
just being sexually responsible teen
pregnancy can ruin people's lives no you
and being with stacked books like this
how was black car bro not immediately
texting Sarah to alert her of his
arrival so she would know to keep Lane
from seeing him on the street I guess we
needed a way for Sarah to get involved
in the story a bit more and figuring out
a clever way to do that would have been
too hard this is where Debbie died we
have to play here actually according to
the Ouija rules I found on the Internet
it's a bad idea to play a Ouija board
where somebody tragically died Lane
didn't invite Debbie's boyfriend to
their little party so he could provide
us with this another fake out jumpscared
also someone should check out that light
switch it makes a horribly loud
cinemasins title card sound when someone
turns it on a few rows first like you're
never supposed to play in a graveyard
hey no one said the rules had to be
relevant its element eyesores
he's right which is kind of disturbing
when you think about it next to monopoly
is a board used to communicate with dead
people if there's a presence here please
make yourself known I know Lane thought
her friend was acting weird and she felt
something when she came to the house
earlier but God's name made her think
the Ouija board must actually work and
junk when I was here yesterday was that
you I had to pause and think about what
that question meant for a minute because
her recon mission at the house was so
boring I couldn't remember what happened
who is this
Debbie Lane is presumptuous in assuming
the D is for Debbie it could be David no
Doris or the ghost you don't know calm
down it's an old house I'm starting to
think this guy is working with the
ghosts old houses do make creaks and
squeaks when people are moving around in
the things don't loudly bang when
everyone's sitting still tell the lights
group of unsuspecting teenagers seem
unfazed by the paranormal activity and
subsequent power outage they just
experienced for all I know it was late
maybe it was really something she needed
yeah and I guess the power outage was
laying to those continues to enjoy
turning on the burner for a maximum
boring effect Debbie did she do this no
but I heard you did Dallas Deb is that
you turn off the burner
it's our reflection in the mirror and
then someone pushed me from behind she's
not very creative this ghost will have
to beat this thing using our finger
paints also Pete has a magical head that
is impervious to hard smacks into a
mirror why do you bring it out also why
wait until you're at the front door to
ask why she's taking it home you should
never touch these things as always the
Hispanic housekeeper seems to know about
everything supernatural and warns the
white people about being stupid well my
girlfriend spooked out and I just played
with a Ouija board time to ride my
bicycle through an aqueduct who is that
who cares you're in a public place it's
a home dude grocery good also how did
this movie get a sequel again oh it made
20 times its budget maybe the sin
shouldn't be on the studio that made
this but the people who bought tickets
so if Doris is trapped and controlled by
a mother which we will find out later
how is she able to go around trolling
Lane and all her friends are you sure
this ghost isn't Casper or at least a
deadmau5 fan girl is scared alarmed by
exterior door shutting behind her which
is the thing exterior doors tend to do
doris writes hi friend under that flyer
to create this traumatic reveal isabel
opens the car door after seeing
tremendous evidence of a psycho killer
in the back seat I'll pick you up I'll
be there in a few minutes this guy keeps
getting more bone than everyone else it
gets his head smashed by a mirror and
while everyone else is hi friend
messages are written chalk or
condensation this guy's desk gets
completely ruined apparently Doris the
ghost child from the 50s has enough
computer knowledge to open lanes
computer because it wasn't open yet and
type in lanes passcode that she knew and
type and enlarge the hi friend in the
middle of this pages document I wonder
if she was initially thrown off because
the QWERTY keyboard since the Ouija
boards just alphabetical oh and the
computer shuts off because you know goes
things I think we should say the board's
together right because they all know
them now the first time they play doris
had no need to pull out the chair she
has to do it this time because it's
scarier
this ghost isn't even trying like I'm
almost surprised one of these kids
hasn't said come on haunt me
motherfucker you're gonna bore me to
death if you didn't do this who did did
someone hurt you did Lane fails to ask
who this is initially even though the
spirit is acting particularly snippy
this time easy where are you I'm
starting to think Lane had a short-term
memory loss she couldn't remember that
she and Debbie talked about Ouija right
before she died and just now she forgot
about that chair that clearly has
something supernatural sitting in it
ghosts fast forwards through the movie
and I should give it a synonym for doing
that but it could have done this a lot
sooner so nut mouth girl points out the
horrible monster of a mother who we find
out later is actually trying to prevent
her demon spawn of a daughter from
killing people so cuz up with this angry
mom slash bear slash dragon approach he
has to the living what if we broke some
sort of rule even though doris was able
to communicate with them when they were
at their own homes they all assumed none
of the ghosts can leave the house or
communicate when they aren't using the
board since they are standing on the
front porch like they aren't in any
danger a dead friend in a Ouija board
connect us together while we go through
the banality of high school face Debby
records her cleaning the Attic escapades
that reveal how and where she found the
Ouija board because she was directed to
by the screenwriter I guess they got her
so weird that's exactly where it was at
the very beginning of the movie when
they were kids it's like it magically
transported itself to the original
location where already was stored also
thanks for the exposition there I was
worried that we G board came from some
Native American burial ground or
something but this video proves what is
chillingly boring not only does Isabel
not drive her Honda CRV into a nearby
pond and light the pond on fire but she
feels safe enough to continue driving it
like nothing happened I almost want to
send them for not having someone stand
behind her when she shuts the
medicine-cabinet because they've hid all
the other horror cliches pretty hard Wow
alright you talked me into it but why
why is she first why did the ghost
travel to her house and do this isn't
all the freaky happening at Debbie's
house also this is the primary reason
why I don't floss also did Doris
instantly fill the tub with more water
because there is no way it filled up
that quickly so there it is
death by sewing also rest in peace
Isabelle you didn't do anything but at
least you did it well you have no idea
what you're talking about the scene
where a school counselor tries to offer
help d'Alene was accidentally left in
for some reason it's haunting us
watching everything we do
so it's like final destination six Ouija
mania I can get behind that and Club it
to death it's just us now
lane apparently forgot about her sister
hey master I Debbie found it
you mean the exact location as specified
by the video that's looking amazing also
it's the Attic she cleaned out which
makes me wonder why Lane thinks she's
gonna find anything and also makes me
wonder why Debbie didn't find the old
photos Lane soon finds also discount
old-timey kirsten dunst if the only
entryway to the attic is through w
closet then how the hell did they get
that chair up there goddamn if everyone
in this movie would just move with some
urgency when they heard something that
would probably cut the runtime down to
45 minutes creepy doll in a horror movie
cliche how much what ever has this ghost
study this is perhaps the most pointless
scare since the time I told my
girlfriend I'm late and I'm never late
that one month Doris uses her selective
invisibility powers because she knows
were two-thirds of the way through a
movie and she can't fully reveal herself
just yet because that would ruin all the
fun despite having unparalleled power to
go wherever she wants and kill people
this ghost can't kill the main character
in the main house where all that is
going down this is a family for some
reason they're still connected to the
house with all those photos scattered
across the table why is this picture the
first one we're seeing of the whole
family look at these photos I'd say this
is the late forties the early 50s
honestly I don't know why anyone would
question my authority I audited a
psychosexual criminal photography class
once so I think I know what I'm talking
about
apparently this family only took
pictures in front of their front door
and just playing with the Ouija board
watch out Google you've got search
breathing down your neck it stands for a
sentient extensive archival research
computer hub and it's about to Skynet
your ass also Pete was able to
immediately scroll to the right article
so we can spend very little time on the
research portion of this horror film
because we have a lot more painfully
slow suspenseful sneaking around to do
Laine you should come look at this you
should come take a look at this cliche
she used to live in Debbie's house with
her mother and this guy not read or
something I believe there's a presence
in that house that sometimes leaves to
etch hi friend into walls and desks and
kill one of the characters in their
house when the movie needs a death scene
my mother practiced maybe a machete
is that even a word and then something
went wrong with mother she couldn't turn
it off let me guess she kept telling
everyone I don't do that anymore but
kept doing it anyway and then got killed
by an old woman in the further you
played in a graveyard
Ruby tries to pass the house off as a
graveyard so it meets the silly rule
they keep repeating even though you
can't call a house that has a dead body
in the basement a graveyard now that
someone's acknowledged my presence I
will now attack in a manner inconsistent
with all the other attacks in this movie
so far
dragging someone across the floor cliche
my god is there some checklist of
cliches that every horror film is
subject to in order to get a green light
lay incorrectly decides that this great
obstructed by a pallet leads the way to
the secret room because the director
whispered in her ear where it was
alerted her that the movie only has 15
minutes left and she needs to hurry up
mother is doing a good job at picking
off old lanes friends but is doing a
rather new job it's stopping Lane from
cutting the mouth stitches even though
she can operate around and it's
imperative that Lane doesn't do that
thank God for Peter Jackson figuring out
that nazgul sound otherwise we would
have no idea what an evil spirit yelling
sounded like so as it turns out cutting
the thread of her sewn up mouth makes
her worse but weren't people already
dying I mean what kind of shocking twist
is it when you do something for the
alleged victim and that's a worse thing
that you can do it's called ripping off
the ring I think Doris wastes time
appearing as Debbie because just showing
up and killing them would be too easy
because my friend Pete another friend is
dead you can see how much it affects me
three friends dead in a week yeah I
think you can see the devastation your
mother didn't try to hurt us she tried
to stop us she did it by screaming at us
like a horror movie villain and throwing
Brown whenever she was pissed so it's
just a case of mixed signals as long
also I'm calling bullshit on this twist
because if Doris was trapped by her
mother and Laine freed her then how the
hell was she able to kill all the kids
before she was free it wasn't even in
the house when she killed Isabelle so
what the fuck has changed you have to
break the connection or it will keep
coming back for you thank God the
housekeeper is so well informed on all
the supernatural mumbo jumbo with the
parents out of town I don't think these
high school kids could have afforded a
Zelda Rubinstein also lain waits until
now to talk to Nona about the connection
she's made with a spirit even though
she's clearly knowledgeable about
spiritual things if she had gone
straight to Nona a person who she seems
to have a good relationship with they
all could have avoided a serious amount
of heartache also when the hell are
Debbie's parents coming back after the
ghost is clear
Sarah this ghost knows exactly who to
imitate to leave this guy to his death
but also didn't think to do it until
they got to the big finale
could have done it at his house but now
we are right up at the end of this damn
thing that we are still spending full
minutes just walking around this ghost
having ripped off nearly every horror
movie finally rips off the Blair Witch
Project at its systematic theft is
complete Wayne doesn't decide at this
point to just burn the house down it's
clearly the best choice the board and
the body are both in there and that
would take care of any other twisty
garbage that might be lurking in the
house if she's convicted she can go live
in that nice Correctional Facility with
Elise Trevor explodes because you
fine even with both Lane and Sarah in
the house Doris takes her time killing
them because Lane and Sarah needs some
time to defeat her his friend this time
single dammit you should have locked
that but all the chairs from the
conjuring - to prevent that from
happening this ghost is on repeat I
killed the last guy no problem you
however I'm going to turn into a damsel
in distress
hahahahaha George decides to so Sarah
off the old fashioned way instead of
just looking at her and her mouth being
instantly sewn shut that would just be
quick and unsatisfying door isn't
playing alone you have to play that's in
the rules as written by Hasbro
incorporated so you can see the binder
in yeah but huh why also Lane's arm is
broken at this point yet when Debbie
shows up and turns her arm back around
daddy heals it I guess
I don't believe you but let's think
about these deaths for a second why are
Lane and Sarah not being extensively
questioned by the cops right now one guy
drowned or was suffocated by bubble wrap
and the guy from Percy Jackson - like he
died I think but all we saw was Zink
turning gray in his mouth getting so
nobody's asking questions this is the
second sexy flossing scene we've seen in
this movie we G brought to you by the
American Dental Association did the evil
spirits just leave her the planchette
seems like a particularly lazy way to
give this movie an open-ended ending the
end nothing happened to her it's this
guy on the Ouija board of directors
[Music]
really
she's draw pictures of what our dorms
would look like everything was purple